for me this is just as someone that's
Generation X I see a lot of Millennials
that seem more competitive and maybe
it's just because the world has
tightened up and it is it everything is
now more competitive what you're feeling
about competition because there's good
and bad to it and sometimes if people do
get wrapped up and I think we've all
been guilty of it uh yeah I I think that
acting people tend to think of it as a
competitive thing but I I've been really
trying to make a conscious effort
because I've been guilty that to not
look at other people and look I mean you
can look and admire and be like wow that
guy he's my age and he did a brilliant
job in this but I can't compare myself
to anyone else's path because the
interesting thing about the
entertainment industry's everybody has a
different path yeah I'm really
competitive with myself you know I know
I can do better I know I can be better i
know i can i can work harder so I'm
really just competitive with myself and
competitive I I hold myself to a high
standard as far as work ethic and trying
to improve all the time and also there's
a certain you know like I said there's a
certain lifestyle as far as working all
the time that's a lifestyle I want I
want to be working a lot i want to be
working on a great stuff and doing great
work and uh yeah it's hard to balance
that and then you know not try to be
good you know acting is about living in
it and you can't try to be good or
you're not really doing a good job at
acting so there's it's hard to balance
those two
you